[Music]
greetings future
uh
moonling
yeah that's right you are among the
first generation of children born on the
moon
how would your birth compare to every
previous humans
would your body be physically different
from an earthlings
and what challenges would you face if
you traveled to earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were born on the moon
if you were born on the moon you'd begin
your life 384
400 kilometers away from where every
other human being has ever been
born at least as far as we know
the surface of your birthplace would
have an extremely thin atmosphere
without liquid water
the radiation levels could be up to 1
000 times higher than on earth's surface
and the scorching daytime temperatures
at the equator get as high as 120
degrees and as frigid as minus
130 degrees at night
of course your mother wouldn't give
birth to you out on the moon's surface
your life would begin in a
state-of-the-art base surrounded by a
handful of astronauts but with six times
less gravity than on earth
would being born on the moon be
extremely dangerous
you know being born on the moon wouldn't
be nearly as dangerous as writing
without grammarly
communication matters no matter where
you are in life or what you do a text to
grandma can be just as important as a
work email especially in my family and
with grammarly every word you write will
communicate what you want clearly and
concisely
great writing isn't just about being
correct it's about style
grammarly premiums vocabulary
suggestions keep my writing natural
while still retaining my voice so
whether i'm at the office or on the
couch my message stays on point and
right now what if viewers can get 20 off
grammarly premium at grammarly.com
what if that's 20 off at
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash what if
if you're not using grammarly you might
as well stay on the moon
right now a moon base is only
theoretical
your first home on the moon might be a
habitat based on project horizon
it was a concept proposed by the u.s
military in 1959
whether the base got built into caves
using pressurized airbags or a high-tech
cylindrical airlock dug into the surface
you'd be born into an incredible
self-sustaining habitat
you'd harvest the oxygen you'd breathe
and the water you'd drink from the
moon's natural environment
your birth wouldn't have been a walk in
the park for your parents either
since you'd be the first space baby
there wouldn't be any research on the
challenges of conceiving a child in
space
but your folks were successful and
you probably wouldn't want to hear much
about that anyway
the moon's lower gravity would have made
your birth especially challenging
as a fetus you'd have developed slower
so the length of time your pregnant
mother carried you could have been
longer than on earth
imagine being pregnant in space for up
to one full year
your birth would likely have taken
longer than back on earth too
for every month your mother is spent in
space she could have lost about one to
two percent of her bone density
that would have made pushing you out a
lot more difficult
and dangerous
with the risk that giving birth could
fracture your mother's pelvic bone
the doctors in your space habitat would
have brought you into the world using a
c-section operation
and every baby born on the moon after
you would likely be born this way too
this could lead to one of the first big
differences between earth and moon
babies
our heads evolved to be small enough to
fit through the birth canal so with no
traditional childbirths on the moon
future moonlings could evolve to have
bigger heads than their earth
counterparts
moonborne children could even evolve to
have different skin color than the folks
back on earth
the melanin in our skin protects us from
the sun's radiation
and the darker your skin the more
natural protection you have
but there's no atmosphere on the moon so
you'd live with significantly less
protection from radiation
so the skin color of future moonlings
could evolve to be extremely dark to
provide the protection they'd need
but since a lot of your life would be
spent inside a habitat or wearing a
spacesuit
well the opposite could be true
humans on the moon could evolve to be
even paler than some people on earth
the increased radiation could cause
other changes too
if earthlings and moonlings didn't
produce enough offspring together
you could even see a new species of
humans emerge
okay well that could take a few hundred
or even thousands of generations but
you'd have been the starting point in
this incredible evolution of humanity
how much you interact with people from
earth would be a tricky question for you
not enough mingling and your immune
system could weaken
you could lose your ability to fight off
infections brought to your base by
visitors to be safe you might minimize
your contacts with new astronauts or
settlers
the last thing you'd want is to start
the first pandemic on the moon
and if you ever made the trip to earth
you'd find it pretty hard to adapt
first of all you'd need a week or two
just to adjust to the gravity and you'd
be plagued by lightheadedness each time
you stood up since the reflexes that
regulate your blood pressure would be
accustomed to lunar gravity not earth's
be careful when jumping into any bodies
of water too
you're from a place where you have to
live inside and conserve water
so
diving could be hard for you
you could get disoriented and
accidentally dive deeper
instead of returning to the surface
now you could find that having a good
view of the earth makes up for the
challenges of visiting it
if you live on the near side of the moon
you'd be able to see earth all the time
earth would even cast extra light onto
you
yeah the earth reflects approximately 37
of the sunlight it receives so on the
moon your view of the planet could be 43
times brighter than the view an
earthling has looking up at you
hopefully you wouldn't grow up to be a
light sleeper who needs total darkness
you awake
yeah
you'd be constantly bathed in both
sunlight and earth shine
well if that happens maybe you could
move over to the far side of the moon
and enjoy its constant darkness
and with such a thin atmosphere
you'd see stars even during the
brightest parts of the day
being born on the moon would come with
its pluses and minuses but would it be
even cooler if you were born somewhere
else
like on mars
well
that's a story
for another
what if
you